what's happening you bad [__]
it's october the fourth monday
the joint is brought to you by
blue chew listen
it's trick or treat time [__] and
uncle joey's got a real treat for you
with blue chew
the falls here the leaves are changing
and you're still not slinging dick you
understand me blue chew's here to change
that i want you to sling dick with
confidence you like uncle joey what's a
[__] blue chew blue chew is an online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis at a
fraction of the cost you could take it
any time
day or night the process is simple sign
up at bluetooth.com and talk to their
licensed medical providers once you're
approved
you'll receive the prescription within
days the best part is it's all online no
sitting like a [__] momo at the
doctor's office no cute
nurses giggling in the [__] corner
you know
that's it it ships right to your door in
a discreet package not even your mailman
knows bluetooth tablets are made in the
same usa
prepared and shipped directly it's way
cheaper than the pharmacy so if you can
benefit from the extra confidence i'll
make your dick be [__] blue you
understand me with veins coming out of
it when it's time to perform
show up with blue chew and they got a
special deal for you you ready
try blue chew for free what are you
talking about free
free with promo code joey
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free and as always i want to thank blue
chew for sponsoring the joint
bluechew.com
promo code joey
make your dick as big as it can [__]
be and get ready to sling it
[Music]
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen
it never hurts to have a few bucks in
your [__] pocket
of course not right who doesn't draft
king sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the nfl has an offer
every football fan should jump on
for week five new customers bet just one
dollar on any football game and you got
100 and free bets
who's better than the [__] uncle joey
showing up with that are you kidding me
or what
the last 0-0 tie in the nfl was in 1943
that's older than uncle joey if your
sports book isn't available in your
state yet draftkings won't leave you
empty-handed you understand me everybody
can play for huge cash prizes all season
long with the draftkings daily fantasy
sports contest
daily are you listening to me
daily
sports contests draftkings is giving all
new customers a free shot at a million
dollars in total prizes with their first
deposit at draftkings daily fantasy
sports for comp
contest download this draftkings fantasy
app and
the sports betting app why [__] around
you might as well do ads are better than
one
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey throw a dollar
on any nfl game
and i'll put a hundred dollars in free
bets in your [__] pocket if either
team scores a point who's better than
you
nobody that's promo code joey on this
week's draftkings book app the official
sports betting partner the nfl ufc you
don't like betting football i get it
they got a [__] tremendous casino
roulette blackjack poker we can bet on
golf we can bet on tennis you can bet on
basketball you can bet on [__] the
baseball playoffs which start today now
here's the stuff the lawyers make me say
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pa
west virginia colorado new customers
only
i'll give you the dollar you bet it you
get a hundred dollars on if the team
wins or loses you can't beat that
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
now if you got a gaming problem call
1-800 gambler
if not do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app and win some
[__] guitars if not download
the draftkings fantasy app and let's win
some real [__] getus
the joint is also brought to you by
c b
d [__] lion the best in cbd how
do i know because it's brought me back
from a [__] surgery that's how i know
and it's brought me back from anxiety
you got some anxiety you try that cbd
line the 1500 milligram
dropper unbelievable it's all a drop
rate for you they got kinesiology tape
they got capsules
they got a
cream a chill
they got
listen vapor pens the gummy bears to die
for with the melatonin you cannot beat
that products at cbdlion.com
go there right now read about cbd and
how it could be advantage to you
press in code joey or join and get 20
off of the cbd products delivered right
to your [__] house you can't beat
that it's the best cbd on the market how
do i know because like i said to you
from the roll-on to the tape
to the cream
to the to the bath ball i mean they give
you no options they give you
every option
to have cbd line in your life so go to
cbd line right now
press in joey or joint and get 20 off to
live at the house let's get this party
started it's monday morning the 4th of
october
why [__] around
come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
greetings from podcastville you bad
[__] it's monday
october the [__] fourth
we did it it's over the movie is out
whether you liked it or not i don't give
a [__] i had a great time uh
it was great to [__] do i had a great
weekend i mean the weekend was just [__]
i couldn't ask for a better weekend man
i don't even know
where i would fit stand up into my life
now it's not that
you know it used to be i don't have time
for [__] now i don't have time for stand
up it's it's just
it's insane this upcoming week
i'm out
six nights in a row
monday game wednesday game friday game
tuesday and thursday kickboxing
saturday kids party at night 5 30
[__] party it's a beautiful [__]
life man
so uh we watched the movie i hope all
you guys watched it i hope you had a
great [__] week
everybody had their [__] opinions and
i loved it i listened guys for a guy
like me this started
in 2000
i remember reading for them and
my hands were [__] shaking
as i was
auditioning my hands were shaking my
hands were basically [__] shaking i
remember walking out of there and going
up i'm never gonna get a roll here i
didn't get it i auditioned
maybe uh
four f
five different times for gg the stand-up
comic i mean it was just and i was
bummed out listen when you get
experienced in acting it's a numbers
game guys
you know it's a numbers game if you go
on five auditions
you're gonna get three call backs and
you're gonna get
one roll that's how i look at it that's
my percentages it doesn't usually work
out that way sometimes you do ten
auditions
you don't hear from nobody for [__]
seven of them in a row
and then the eighth one is a call back
the ninth one is a call back and
producers and a pin
and the tenth one
is they call you back right off the
[__] bat it's just numbers so you
can't really when you audition you can't
take it home with you and be stressing
out for four [__] days because it
won't work out for you trust me what i'm
telling you i was the king of this the
whole thing with life that i just
figured out when i was sitting there
watching this movie it's two things guys
it's experience
and maturity
i wasn't when i first ran for the
sopranos when i was
42 years old
i wasn't prepared for the [__] role
there was no way i wasn't ready yet
you know one thing i learned from
watching that movie in the movie theater
wednesday night like i was telling mike
i've watched it four times already
i watched the screening of it i watched
the premiere i watched the screening of
it in
union and i watched the screening of it
and eaten town
the first two
times i watched the movie was just to
watch it
just to pick it up just to see what the
[__] happened and i enjoyed it the first
time i did not enjoy it because it was a
small screening room i enjoyed it in the
theater and i enjoyed it in the theater
again
at the amc's just it was tremendous
experience with the folding [__]
chairs and you know the whole goddamn
thing
you have to watch in the theater at home
it's not gonna work out for you it's
just you don't get the full experience
from it it's it'll knock it off by 50
[__] percent it's just it's like that
with every movie i've seen a bunch of
movies and i've done experiments in my
head i hate watching movies at home it
just doesn't work unless you're alone
and even then it's a [__] nightmare
because you got to get up to pee
pop who's not [__] calling you you
know that's why i hate going to movies
in the daytime because there's business
being [__] done so i'm sitting in the
movie theater i'm finally settling in
i'm finally starting to have a good time
and boom my [__] phone goes off and i
i don't get up to answer you know i'll
keep watching a movie but now it grows
in your head like a [__] weed that
why is this guy calling you did
something happen that he fall off his
[__] skateboard you know you don't
[__] know so now you got to get up
and that you just missed four [__]
minutes for nothing
a couple months ago i was at church
a friend of mine called me once no
problem i'm not gonna go outside
she called me again
i wonder what the [__] going on then
she called again in 15 [__] minutes i
walked outside i'm i'm sweating bullets
and something happened to my [__]
friend
she asked me what do you know about this
guy i think i got a crush on
i go you called me three [__] times
to tell me that
you know so you know
you never [__] know what you're gonna
yeah on a sunday [__] morning at 11
o'clock she bumped into him saturday at
the park
and she thought he was cute yeah he's
[__] 55 56 years old like me he's
[__] cute great
so you know you never know what [__]
phone call you're answering and [__] so
i try to [__] keep it simple but
that's what i realized while i was
watching that movie
this movie wasn't based on
my years of
a year of comedy this movie came from 23
years of hard work if you're a young
comic
or a young actor i want you to keep that
in mind
i want you to keep in mind that if they
go to you with a project of this
magnitude early on
and you book it and you're not prepared
and the word gets out you're finished
so
if you ever book a film like this to
this caliber whether it's the longest
yard
grudge match one thing i learned was i
was always
prepared you know i'm not an actor by
trade
i didn't go to russia to study acting
with john bernthal you know he did he
really went to russia i mean he's a bad
[__] you know alessandro is a
bad [__] corey stahl
is a bad [__] do i have to tell
you what ray leota is i mean listen the
movie's out now so i can tell you guys
about this
you know it's uh
it's basically
my second day or third day of [__]
shooting all right
and
i don't know if you watched the movie or
not we'll break down the scenes real
quick for you
my first the first scene i basically
shot
was me in the room when he kicks the tv
when dickie montesante
that was my first scene
and i remember
that i was improvising and now
if you notice i had no lines i was
trying to get a line in you know uncle
joey right you got to get your [__]
line in
something funny something whatever i i
don't know what i said
okay but after he kicked the tv
and he yell at us i would crack a joke
and they were funny we were giggling
[__] amongst ourselves you know whatever
after about 10 takes
12 takes
because you got to shoot it from every
[__] angle
i remember one of the guys coming up to
me
and going listen
just to give you a heads up
david don't like it when you improvise
stick to the script and that script you
have no lines in there there's a reason
trust me
my feelings didn't get hurt i understand
writing i understand the process of
writing and i know that
with somebody as calculated as david
chase
it's gonna come back later on to be
relevant
so let me just
do what they want to
and we'll [__] move the [__] on so we
did it
but during that scene something else
happened that i watched him shoot
something in the at the funeral for
hollywood dick
and i realized that everything was very
tight
and then i sat there for a while and i
thought of all the episodes that i had
watched how the acting was very tight
and i go i get what he's trying to do
so the second scene i shot
was when i asked junior if he's got
diarrhea
and they put the tv down
again
i tried to be cute
and i'm surprised they kept what am i
gonna do with this [__] thing anyway
i'm very surprised that was an
improvised line
my original line was whatever three c's
cash
that was it but that's
that scene when the silence is in the
air when we're just left there looking
at each other
i couldn't have that silence
but that's what makes david chase the
genius that he is
he wanted to create that silence
so again that was when i caught on
that's why that scene
is possibly my best scene in the movie
because
i was already on board mentally for that
so now i had a few days off i went up to
milwaukee
i went to [__] uh
chicago or something milwaukee and
something else minnesota
and i come back i got monday off thank
god
because my body was broken from the week
before
the late [__] nights in new york and
the uh you know
the flying
so monday i'm off i [__] go to a
kickboxing class across the street i
take it easy i do some laundry
and tuesday i gotta go back in there now
it's the second time i meet ray liotta
so i meet him his trailer is close to
mine
i meet him
you know i said i met him at the table
right but i see him in the morning i say
good morning what's going on
big day today it was the scene inside
side tree house
so i go to make up you know hair about
an hour later
eat breakfast you know you look at your
[__] sheets for the day
i go over i'm sitting in the makeup
trailer and who's sitting next to me
with ray liotta
you know i'm a good guy guys and i'm a
hard worker and even though i knew my
[__]
i just wanted to see how it flowed
that's what a stand-up does right when
you're a stand-up you go home you write
your stupid [__] jokes then you go on
stage and you [__] try them and if
they don't work after three times you
say [__] them back to the drawing board
so even with acting
if i have lines i want to read them with
mike before i do it so i learned maybe
there's something i'm missing maybe
there's a pause i didn't catch
so i said ray do you want to [__] do
the lines do you know this [__]
just looked at me
like he just went
and he went back to his makeup
i didn't say nothing you know uncle joey
i i said maybe he knows his lines better
than me maybe he's a method actor i have
no [__] idea
i'm just gonna run with it right so i go
back to my [__] trailer
boom make up call you know put your
wardrobe on you're about to shoot we go
back it's an early morning [__] shoot
i'm sitting there as you guys saw i'm
sitting next to ray i got puss next to
me
i got paulie on the stove i got uh
somebody in front of me it doesn't
matter junior is walking around silvio's
at the phone you know taking numbers
was sitting there and boom the scene
starts you know
and sure enough i say my line
and he has to tell the sinatra story
and it's just not working
it's not working
it's all over the [__] place and the
and the scripty girl is yelling at him
right it's this
i know
ray it's this i know ray it's this i
know so now i got to be honest with you
guys i'm starting to get a little pissed
off here because i'm the [__] most
unprofessional [__] i know i'm a
comedian
i'm a [__] [__] and i know that
that's a david chase production and i
want to be prepared but something i've
noticed the last 10 years
the [__] every time i go on a set the
biggest names
they don't know their lines they get so
much work thrown at them
and it's not their fault listen after a
while you're shooting junk for [__]
20 years
you know every script
sounds the same even though people tell
you where do you read that script that
moved me no it didn't
it was just a [__] whatever you know
what i'm saying so every script sounds
the same
when i get a job now because of who i am
and how i do things because of me
i read the script even though it's
painful sometimes
i read the script with this
i couldn't read the script mr chase
didn't want you to have a script so you
couldn't build an arc in your [__]
mind like you always want your character
to have some type of art i didn't build
an ark inside my mind but i did once i
saw the movie i go jesus christ my ark
was [__] okay there you know
everything was fine
so i take that [__] kind of seriously
so after like 10 [__] tanks
even though he's a senior
actor and he's done a lot more than me
or whatever
my feelings were a little hurt you know
i went out there with my [__] hand
open
and now you don't know the [__] lines
you know so i'm like ray
what the [__] you know
you're supposed to know your [__]
lines he's doing the lines he's spitting
food and [__]
so so
everybody started torturing like ray
what the [__] ray what the [__] you know
ray what the [__] eventually he just
left
he just left it was just us shooting
around him there was just a guy sitting
there we were just doing the [__]
lines it was tremendous
but you know it's ray liotta it's ray
liotta
it's a david chase production you know
you don't want to be rude
whatever happened at the table happened
at the table we were busting his balls a
little bit
but we weren't going to say it's not
you're going to get up and go what the
[__]
this guy didn't know his [__] lines
you know what uh you know that's not
what it's all about so
we're sitting there later on three four
hours later it's midnight
that you know that that's changing
[__] cameras and [__] so you have to
break in between
usually sit down get a cup of [__]
hot cocoa maybe some peanut m ms
whatever an espresso whatever the [__]
you're into
and i'm sitting there
and somebody not me goes
what the [__] was up with ray before
listen
like six people just fell on the floor
laughing because
nobody's gonna say nothing you know i'm
saying like so we had a good [__]
laugh we laughed for like 20 minutes
people were like what the [__] was that
today i'm like i don't know but don't
you know so sure enough we shoot a
couple more hours we get
we wrap
you know we get in the trailer we we
change into [__] wardrobe
and we're taking a shuttle back into
manhattan that drops us off on 33rd and
3rd
or 36th and 3rd it really doesn't
[__] matter so
we're headed over in the shuttle it's a
long day
everybody's quiet in the car
there was a sweetheart makeup girl that
didn't say dick
and she was sitting in the back and she
goes
what the hell was up with ray liotta
today and we're like wow
we didn't know what the [__] was up
so when i went to see the movie the
first [__] time
i didn't know what to expect from
rayleigh hilda now there was two
rayleigh odors as you guys saw i'm sorry
about the spoiler alert
i thought the second ray liotta who
played sal
was so [__] brilliant
it was crazy let me tell you something
else about ray
focus on the scene in the very beginning
the
confirmation scene
not when he's showing the priest a
picture
but when he's sitting there looking
straight ahead like a [__] charles
manson
and carmine
who's played by nick balalanga
comes over and he goes who's that maria
lots of pizza and he goes get the [__]
out of here you [__] mutt
i want you to focus on his face if you
watch it on tv
and slow it down
and watch how when the words come out
his face changes before he even delivers
the lines
that's
brilliant [__] acting
you know i've been watching this [__]
for years i love
zeroing in on people am i a good actor
not at all i just act very naturally and
i play me when i play me it's easy to be
you you know i don't like it don't take
no [__] genius when [__] uh
joe pesci won the oscar for goodfellas
it was very easy
he was playing him
he was playing him when you're playing
you like a role that comes to you like
that so when i do these movies i'm
basically playing me i can't [__] act
i'm no actor i know the basics of it i
know how to breathe and how to [__]
you know my whole stand-up was always
written
but delivered improvised so you thought
it was being said the first time i've
worked on being organic like that you
know since day one and that's what i was
thinking when i was watching this movie
how
holy [__]
it took me 23 years to work to get this
movie
like it took me all the 23 years i spent
in l.a
to perform the way i did in this movie
it wasn't that would have not been that
way if i would have just got
went to an acting class and i was 35
years old
there's no [__] way
the reason why i did as well as i did
was because
everything i did led up to that role if
i never work on a feature film again
it's fine with me and i've said this
since i shot the movie because the movie
was so high caliber for me
that it really doesn't matter
i'll never be in that greater company
again
but i'm hoping i will you know i'm
saying like i'm hoping that
now is the start of an acting career and
the only way to get an acting career
kicking
when you're a guy in my position
is to close the door on stand
nothing happens nothing happens until
you close one door then another one
opens you know so we all know that so
this is what i'm thinking about right
now this is what's been on my mind
for the last few months you know i'm not
saying i'm done with stand-up but you
know you got to close one door before
another one opens and if i want i i
really this is my dream guys
to be on some [__] i'd really love to
be on lawn on a couple episodes a season
i don't want to be a star i don't want
to
just a little you know i was a big lenny
[__] brisco [__] fan
you know i'm a cop fan
to have the organized crime show now the
show's been on forever
if i get on that [__] show i would do
whatever three seasons
i'd make it to 62 or 63 hopefully
somebody shoots me
and i [__] move the [__] on you know
what i'm saying once you get i've been
shot in two mob movies already that's
tremendous i was shot and analyzed that
in the very beginning and i was shot in
this movie you know the difference on
the two movies i analyzed that you don't
see me get shot with bullets
this one you see my head fly off like a
[__] pumpkin
and it was [__] tremendous guys i
remember when i was reading the table
read
and i saw that i was like god damn it
and i wasn't bummed because i was
getting shot i was bummed because if
you've ever shot a [__]
movie or tv show where there's blood
involved it's a nightmare
when you're getting shot because
they shoot you and then there's a puerto
rican with a bucket filled with like
fake blood like billy gold blood like
[__] carry and they throw it at you
sometimes the blood lands here that
means you got to do it over again
sometimes the blood hangs in your lands
in your eye like when you come in your
girlfriend's eye sometimes it just
ricochets and it goes in your eye you
got to shoot it over again if the blood
is in time right
you got to shoot it over again so when i
saw that scene i go well there we go i'm
gonna have to change 15 [__] times
one night it sucks dick
but you gotta do and you gotta look
perfect so they gotta scrub you down
put your hair back the way it was if it
got wet they gotta blow dry it i was
like god damn it i'm not looking forward
to it like two days before they were
like hey are you looking forward to your
big scene and i'm like not really like
it's gonna be quick
because we're cgi in it i was like holy
[__]
that was [__] tremendous so like two
days later i went in there they sat me
down they put two lights on my head two
lights in front of me one behind me
they [__] measured my head yeah it
was
it was something from another you know
and a couple years ago i did mafia
whatever the game i don't know
yeah i died in that too so that's three
[__] deaths
in a mafia movie who's better than me
nobody [__] suckers but
uh when i did that one that was also an
education also because when you do those
they just put a black suit on you with
light bulbs
like these little [__] light bulbs so
i look like the [__] michelin man
only with [__] light bulbs all over
me it was it was pretty [__] listen
man
and this is what i'm trying to tell you
this is the name of this episode
maturity and experience
i know a lot of years you know it's like
ray liotta said pain
comes from one thing sure it does
i i had that pain that's why i was
snorting [__] coke like a fiend
because there's nothing more frustrating
in life
that knowing you could do something and
they won't let you do it so you have to
step up to the [__] bump what do i
mean by step up to the [__] pump you
got to get up and go [__] it this is
what i want to do and with me it was
always just like oh we can't get you
into that movie listen man
i've put a thousand feathers in my cap
but one of the feathers that i put my
cap was for is not waiting for
[__] i don't wait for agents
or people like that to [__] do
something i ask you one time and while
i'm hanging up i'm already planning how
i'm gonna [__] reach out to you to
enhance the [__] meeting like even
though my agent's gonna call i'm gonna
call too just to let them know i'm not
[__] the [__] around like i've always
been one of those guys when i first got
to l.a for two or three years all the
roles i was going for would you know i
couldn't even get in for them so i said
[__] it i became friends with this guy
and he told me get me any script
and i said good from now on i'm gonna
start putting my own [__] auditions
on tape and that's what i did you ready
taxi
the longest yard
american gangster which then they recast
and that's my my [__] fault but i
booked it from a tape the other movie
with denzel washington that i got cut
from inside man doesn't matter i got cut
i still sent the [__] tape in you
know
all these movies i got because i was
very aggressive to get them i knew i
could cover the [__] spread analyze
that i went after that like a
[__] i sent the tape to her from
the mezzos and then bought my own plane
ticket to come to new york city i didn't
buy it i was broke my friend gave me a
ticket on [__] uh one of those
airlines one of those economy airlines
not spirit but the other one out of
denver holy [__] they lost my luggage on
the way there i had to audition with no
[__] clothes and i still booked it
that's mental toughness that's where the
maturity comes from and the
[__] experience what do you
think i'm talking about here you [__]
so dive in when you believe you get
something whether you're a guitar player
whether you're a drummer and people are
holding you down you ever join one of
those bands and everybody's a [__]
lap the one kid's rich so he's got the
the best [__] uh
you know the speaker system and the
other guy [__] you know he's like 80
like have you ever seen the motley crew
movie when the [__] when the the guy
is old and he shows up and they hire him
you know he's an old guy and he's kind
of like [__]
he's kind of negative you know you got a
bum you got to bump into all those
[__] but
you have to be on the top of your
[__] game always
you know that's what i learned about
watching this on the big screen that
with me listen the agents they make more
money putting you on the road than they
do in movies they're not going to put
you in movies
so i had to fist fight these
[__]
to put me in that [__] movie like i
had to say get me an audition you know i
missed [__]
uh the englishman i missed [__] the
other [__] movie the irishman the
englishman
yeah they should make an englishman uh
some english [__] gangster the
englishman
it's [__] crazy guys how bad my
memory is from time to time and i'm not
even high this is why i'm happy i don't
get high in the [__] daytime even
though i gotta be honest with you guys
about something
this was a breakthrough [__] week
guys
after a year
a year of [__] with this
anxiety and this [__]
feeling and not being sure of myself
i am back
how do i know
i tried it yesterday in between games
i flew over here to take a [__] [__]
and i was like man there's nothing i
want to do more than smoke a [__]
bowl right now
mike gave me a bowl of a lion
i [__] filled it up with a little bit
of weed just a little bit no [__]
keef
and i hit it oh
i got so nice and [__] high at like
12 o'clock now it was like 1 35
my heart didn't beat because usually
when i get high in the daytime the last
time i got high in the daytime was like
in june
i brought
my friends my neighbors some edibles
across the street
and i had an open bag and i ate at 10
milligrams just because they taste good
now you and i both know
that 10 milligrams does nothing to your
[__] uncle joe you guys know this
right
well i gotta tell you something my
[__] heart went off the [__]
scales
see with the withdrawing that i had any
like them remember the magnesium plus i
was the response from me i think that
product was great
i was resting i was living good i was
eating good but every time i took it it
set off
i don't know what it's called the kindle
the phase i don't know this [__]
withdrawing terminology
but it sets you off a lot of people if
you go on those
benzo websites and whatnot
they'll tell you what medication to take
but when you go into deep
benzo website they'll tell you don't
take nothing because at all
like when i eat chinese food holy [__]
the msp the msg whatever the [__] it is
that [__] sets my heart off and running
like there were so many things like if i
smoked did an edible
drank caffeine in the daytime like the
morning coffee was fine anything after
that would just set me to [__] off there
was times i was sitting in my chair and
the heartbeats were so hard that i could
feel my shoulders from the [__] heart
going this way and that way
i don't i didn't wish this
on anybody this was a mistake i made
it's not like i was taking pills and
drinking with them or getting [__]
high you don't get eye on those [__]
things
you're just doing to stop your [__]
heartbeat
and my heart just rebounded out of
control i'm lucky you know i thought
about going to a clinic and sitting
there for like two months and i was like
i'm not [__] doing that because
everything i read told me that clinics
can't help you it's time
it's time it's working out it's walking
you know i went on there and i took i
watched videos on youtube on it and i
took a little bit from a lot of people
i'll tell you what else helped me a lot
i'll tell you what it's a [__] great
product that i was hooked on when i
first
got it and then you know through time
you switch up a new mood
new mood from [__] on it is
it's [__] bailed me out this time
listen honey has bailed me out with
three of their products on it i
alpha brain bail me out this time that
new black label
that [__] will get your gears running
when you see that my gears are running
it's because the [__] alpha brain the
new mood at night it helps it helps 10
o'clock with my tea
i pop one and
i just started doing this after i saw
somebody talking about new mood i was
like really
all right [__] you and the [__] uh
the [__] that gives you oxygen they're
tremendous
before working out and the one uh
that you take the shroom tech sport and
the shroom tech commune before i would
go on planes
dug the proof was in the pudding i would
have people go on planes with me and
call me the next day i got a cold
i'm fine you know so
that shroom tech immune was [__]
great so these little things that help
um
i took this thing called calm support a
little pricey
but [__] tremendous because it's got
a lot of great vitamins in it so i i
didn't have to take a lot of
vitamins uh
you know
better help put me on uh
she suggested that i go on this
certain anxiety medication burpiton i
don't know what that you know i'm not
good with [__] names
that helped you know that helped a lot
and uh it's great to be able to focus
it's great to not be bummed out anymore
it's great that in between the therapy
and the medication it all worked out for
me and i'm not talking about medication
i'm talking about like alpha brain and
you know
uh
cbd lion the [__] 1500 milligram
silver label
that helped a lot you know i had a lot
of help but there was a lot of [__] that
[__] me up
like the magnesium which was a good
product these are all great products i
bought some vitamins that every time i
would [__] take them i would fly off
the [__] chain
the kratom i bought from your
recommendation some a couple guys
recommended to create them
i think i did it four times and i'm two
for two on it two times it set me off
and running
and two times i actually felt pretty
[__] good on it so
it's all different it's not like i'm
gonna you know i didn't want to take
something like a lot of people recommend
the light oh take a benzo that i don't
live i don't want to [__] have to
taper off ever again i don't ever want
to do this in fact my knees starting to
hurt the left one and i'm not gonna have
[__] surgery right away because of
those pain pills those pain pills
are the worst [__] things in the
world i will stand by
behind what i say 150 [__] percent
it's like smoking a cigarette i smoked
for [__] eight years when i lived in
l.a
i know it's not good for you uh you know
it doesn't take a [__] genius
but you want to know how bad it is
quit smoking for a year
quit smoking for a year and then wake up
do what you used to do spark a cigarette
up when you wake up
and sit there after you take three pups
and sit there and go how bad do i
[__] feel right now like i feel
terrible this is what you're putting
your body through every day it's like
drinking a coke for breakfast you ever
drink a coke for breakfast
i did for [__] 40 years
there was nothing [__] you an orange
juice tropicana with pulp
you could suck the pope off my nut sack
i
[__] pump
i drank a [__] i used to wake up in the
mornings and crack a can of coke put it
over ice and that's the first thing i
drank all day for all you jerk off you
gotta drink a cold glass of water go
[__] yourself you don't know what life
is till you drink a cold [__] coke
but you have no idea what that does to
your body
it destroys your [__] body if you
don't believe me look it up just google
what would a can of coke do for me
before lunch time it sets you off for
the rest of the [__] day it puts your
blood sugar so [__] high you can't
recover did i know this no when i was
drinking 82 [__] cokes a day no i was
having a good time jumping up and down
and [__] you know what i'm saying i love
coke even now sometimes you guys know it
you can't eat chinese food without a
nice can of coke
right you ever try to eat egg foo young
[__] sushi without a can of coke
guess what i do it
i sit there with water like a felon and
[__] and just drink it because that's
that's it that you know you can't drink
diet coke because that makes you [__]
sodium pop up even though friday night
i had a couple of italian short spare
ribs
from [__] uh the feast
guys you don't know what italian spare
ribs onto you get one from the feast i'm
fine i i don't eat spare ribs you guys
know me i i used to love spare ribs a
[__] poo poo platter and some pork
fried rice what what
what
[__] tremendous but no
nothing like that anymore you know i'm
58 i'm an old [__] man so if you're
drinking coke in the morning knock it
the [__] off and if you're smoking
cigarettes when you wake up knock it the
[__] off it's not good for you but i was
trying to tell you earlier that this is
where i [__] this is what this
podcast is about today first of all i've
been doing this podcast for 10 years now
it's not about me goofing on some
[__] little jewish kid it's not about
me [__] coming on here and smoking 55
joints
it's about you guys watching this to
learn something from me to avoid what i
went through to
i'm giving you the [__] playbook
you follow him saying to you i'm giving
you the playbook for free i don't want
none from you [__] this podcast
is free last i [__] checked you just
go on youtube put it the [__] on listen
i don't do this because i want to be
famous i don't want to do this because i
want to be anthony robbins i don't want
to do nothing you understand me i want
to retire and get my [__] horse and
[__] go off into the into the yonder
like [__]
billy ray cyrus and the skinny black
gay kid you know what i'm saying they're
going to ride that horse until uh right
i can't no more you know i'm one of
those guys i'm not looking to be a
[__] movie star none of that [__]
that ship sale you follow me i'm just
looking for you guys
to take [__] from me and go on my uncle
joey said it's [__] maturity there's
nothing you could do sometimes
i know you're an explosive [__]
guitar player i saw you you're the next
eddie van halen but
what happens when i give you two million
dollars
are you gonna [__] get a bag of coke
and and conor mcgregor me to death and
[__] you know
[__] you know become crazy and start
tweeting like trump and you know
these are the things you have to
consider
i don't mind you [__] making a
hundred million dollars i encourage you
anytime one of my friends can [__] the
system i'm jumping up and down for you i
hate the system as much as you guys
[__] do
but what good is it getting to that
plateau if you can't handle it listen
guys if you think i could have handled
what went on with my life the last 10
years when i was 35 in la you guys know
they would have found me in a casket
already i would have been there with
kate quigley that night you know what
i'm saying
you know
you guys think that you know
yeah you guys think that i'm [__]
better than you guys no i'm not i'm
better than you guys because you guys
met me when i was 40 something years old
48 years old or something like that if
you guys would have met me when i was 33
you would have gone we got to stay away
from that [__] guy what's he talking
about
the [__] he talking about
[__] people an [__] what's he
talking about and that's what i'm saying
to you guys
this is all about maturity and what you
can handle at a certain time i'm not
going to give you something that you're
not going to be able to handle i'm not
going to give you something that i know
in two years i'm going to get a call
that you went off a [__] cliff
because you couldn't handle what was
given to you
it's uh it's it's the truth and it's
what i've
i've really
been proud of that i didn't lose my
[__] mind along the way
when i lost my mind after the longest
yard
it wasn't uh a popularity contest losing
your mind it was losing my mind because
i wanted more
i wanted more i wanted it to happen i
thought that i had done a good job in
the longest yard
and i wanted something to come my way
but again if you think i was ready in
2000 [__] five
you got another thing coming because
that's why i went nuts
on the center along the shot like after
three or four months i was telling
people to suck my dick there was a
couple producers that just did not like
me at all and i didn't give a [__]
that's why they took me off the posters
i told a lot of people that they took me
off the posters
because big [__] had gotten into a
fight with his girlfriend they didn't
want me to be confused with big [__] no
they took me off the poster yeah because
big police got arrested for domestic
violence oh at the time
something happened with his girlfriend
and they didn't want that to [__] the
movie that's what i was told in a way
but we all know what really happened i
was acting like a [__] jerk off so
that's what happens i wasn't prepared
for it
one thing about the many saints in
newark and listen after today
it's done we're moving on i just wanted
to wrap it up and do a wrap around on it
so you guys know how i stood i wanted to
tell you some funny stories from the
[__] set but that's it we're not
gonna wednesday's a new [__] realm
we're on i just guys want you to know
um
like i told you guys i think last week
when i came back from new york
one night
i was packing to go back to shoot the
second leg of the sopranos
and i was just putting [__] in my
suitcase and i said to myself how lucky
am i
that i got fired
when i first read for them in 2003 when
i was shooting spider-man how lucky am i
i would have never been able to handle
it
even my behavior on the set
wouldn't have been good
i was on coke you know nothing i would
have done coke on the set
but i would have walked on that set with
the whips of cocaine
and with that negative energy that
cocaine gives you around you so
it would have never worked out so i'm
happy
and i was happy when i got fired because
i knew i wasn't ready for it i didn't
want anybody to see me on coke it's okay
if i did spider-man
and the longest yard and all that [__]
but
i'm telling you guys grudge match i was
very well behaved by that time i wasn't
doing blow i think i was five years
clean i think that came out in 2013.
yeah so i was about six years clean now
it's different
i'm 14 [__] years clean and i can
just feel it on the set even tonight
there's a scene i've been looking at
like i looked at the last two times i
watched it
it's when dickie moltasante is telling
harold
uh the african-american drug runner
that
he's got to leave town he gives them the
500 bucks
in that scene i was very like after the
second time i watched at the premiere
i'm like i gotta watch that [__]
scene
because that's the scene that i was
outside smoking dope at four in the
morning waiting for my uber to come
and they came out and said joey we gotta
unwrap you and the girl was like kind of
scared and i was like jesus thought i
[__] around i didn't give a [__] i
wanted my behavior and my performance
should be perfect on this so i said [__]
it
listen i don't know if you know when
they unwrap you you got to put your
whole wardrobe on if it was a pair of
hot pants and a bra i wouldn't [__]
mind it but it's shoes
italian socks all the way up to your
[__] knees you know those see-through
socks
pants suspenders a white shirt a vest a
jacket my hair it was 20 minutes just to
prepare me by the time i walked back in
it was the scene where he's telling them
to go and they shoot over his shoulder
so they felt they could still see me in
the shot if you look at it i don't even
pop the [__] up so it was a waste of
[__] time it usually is none of that
ten times they're not gonna say it does
nobody even cares
but i remember walking in that night and
[__] around with them and going this
is the most unprofessional
[__] thing i've ever been involved in
in my life
you guys for calling me back at me for
being high and we all just [__]
laughed and had a great time
and that was the thing like i told
people you know i'm not really
uh big on acting like i those long days
and
the attitude of some actors and [__] you
gotta [__] sit them down and tell
them listen how about i [__] stick
the camera up your ass some of them have
a weird none
nobody had a weird attitude on this
[__] set you know i haven't had
maybe the last three sets i've been on
four sets it's been great i did a movie
a couple years ago with alec baldwin and
a bunch of [__] stars
it was an ego festival and you could
smell the [__] in the [__] air i
didn't want to be there alec baldwin was
getting me [__] upset but this was uh
everybody on this movie was [__]
great guys i'm and i'm [__]
happy that a lot of you guys enjoyed
this film i
put everything i got into this [__]
film i don't expect
there's no expectations in my life
on what's going to happen or what's not
going to happen like when i did the
longer shot i was waiting for the phone
to ring
i don't care if the phone rings or if it
doesn't ring like i said i just want a
little gig
a law and order
if they want to put me in the cop show
i'll be a detective i'll be a detective
at the [__] uh at the jail i'll be a
criminal in law and order organized
crime that's what i want to do right now
if some movies come along i'm all in you
know i'm enjoying the [__] podcast
i'm starting to loosen up now so now i
think we're [__] home you know it
took a [__] year to take the stick
out of my ass with the [__] uh
the minor depression the [__] this
was all new to me you know uh so
you know we're shooting with [__]
iphones you know it's a big [__]
different world i was thinking of
switching this [__] studio around for
the year anniversary and making some
things different but we'll see how that
goes
i'm not really in uh
in the mood right now i got a lot of my
[__] plate especially this week but
that's what i wanted to talk to you guys
about today maturity and experience i'll
tell you what made me [__] want to
talk to you guys about this last night i
watched an academy award-winning film i
don't know if it won academy award
but it's an academy award-winning film
in my [__] world
i watched the film boogie nights
you know and it really that movie has
always hit home with me
it was based
in uh you know in a period between like
and 85 which were my [__] troubles
from years you know
um there's a scene in there that just
bothers me because it reminds me of me
when the red-headed chick that plays an
animal elected i forget what her name is
when she goes to the child court and
they won't give her a kid because she's
involved in prostitution or pornography
and drugs
anybody who knows that cuts deep with me
you know
that scene resonates with me a lot and
the other scene is when
[__] marky wahlberg and c riley and
the other guy go to the [__] uh
dr octopus his house have you ever seen
that movie
[__]
when they go to dr octopus's house to
rob him
and he's got the little chinese guy
lighting firecrackers and he keeps
drawing them up in the air and they're
trying to rob him and the tension is
building up and if that's not enough
every [__] four minutes you hear ba
ba
and they're trying to talk and they're
like
and they keep looking at the little
chinese guy and they want to talk and
pop the chinese guy makes a little
[__] [__] firecracker again that
the kid is sitting down just snaps and
he goes i want what's in your safe i
want it all on the floor safe and they
start shooting at each other guys
do you know how many [__] nights
i went to a party at a drug dealer's
house
and that's how the night ended with
people running out because there was a
guy shooting because we were going to
rob him or somebody was going to rob him
oh my god i mean when i lived in north
bergen and in 83 before i went to
colorado
there was a guy that would invite us
over his house
every friday night and he would just
keep putting out coke
putting on coke putting on coke putting
out coke it was ugly
and then he would try to impress the
girls we brought with us so he would
start taking jewelry start taking
jewelry out all his jewelry and we
clocked him as a [__] cop
we were like this guy's a cop when i
gotta [__] with him what's gonna stop
coming up here and sure enough i'm in
colorado and somebody tells me the guy
is dead
somebody killed him on one of those
[__] parties i was like thank god i
don't live there anymore because i would
have been getting the [__] blame for
this that's how you and you know what
the guy was a [__] undercover cop
people got arrested and it wasn't a good
situation when i was in colorado there
was a guy up in aspen that would have
parties it was a gay guy you know he
wasn't really gay he was into everything
eating [__] getting his [__] [__]
he just was one of those dudes that the
cocaine would make him go crazy
sure enough one of him and his butt i
had gone up there a few nights
you know i wasn't great friends with the
guy
but i had a friend that was mutual
friends with him i went up there a
couple nights do you know that one night
he was snorting coke with his [__]
buddies and one of the buddies went in
the room
came out with a [__] machine gun and
shot him up like 10 000 [__] times
with a gun for no reason
for no reason so the [__] early 80s
late 70s
were nuts because the cocaine
would be [__] going into your mind
and you know all of a sudden somebody
would take out a piece somebody would
take out a bb gun
somebody would take out something
but if anything
uh
pops out in that movie at me it's just
what i went through that dark shadow
[__] i mean
the movie smells like cocaine
they lose their mind the [__] burt
reynolds character
fires marky wahlberg
they're so coked out and so [__]
delusional
that they're trying to form a band
it is the worst music in the world
it's like we will rock you we will row
you
we will show you i'm like oh my god this
is terrible then they're arguing with
the [__] studio producer because
they're telling the guy that unless he
pays for the studio time they can't take
the tapes
and see riley's explain to the guy that
if he doesn't have the [__] tapes he
can't get the money from the studio i
mean it was like a drug conversation if
you've ever been a junkie you know
you've had those conversations i'm
looking at this [__] going that was me
right there that was [__] me that
drug [__] mind of always trying to
get a little bit over on people you
could just get a little over on people
if they sell you a gram of coke but you
could squeeze them for a tent to coke
you feel good about yourself that's the
addiction so i'm watching this last
night and i'm like jesus [__] christ
i watched it all the way to the end
until it takes his [__] dick out for
a white dude he had like a 20 inch
[__] thick [__] machine gun
looking dick
it was disturbing but i did it and i
enjoyed the [__] movie i don't like i
said i only watched i didn't want like
some phillip seymour hoffman's in it
but reynolds is in it
the [__] guy gets shot in it from
[__] that one show on showtime
i mean he shoots himself because his
wife's a [__] dirty [__] she's
[__] a bunch of guys but i mean
nothing reminds me more of the 80s and
what i went through
than that movie so that was a great
movie watch on this wrap-up because it
showed me how far i came in my [__]
life
i am very proud of what i did on the
many saints in newark i know a lot of
people are gonna panic
that's got nothing to do with me they
got nothing to do with my [__] dream
and they don't know what i went through
for me it was like i said
23 years went into this movie so i was
as prepared as can be
so when you watch and you go [__]
joey was pretty good in this movie
say yeah but he prepared himself for 23
years so for you young actors and your
young comics
it doesn't happen overnight keep working
take every course that you can
i took every cold reading course i took
every acting course i took everything
that i can invest in yourself
the investment paid off with a high
level [__] movie that was a high
level payment
and it just didn't happen because i was
joe jerkoff it happened because i was a
student of the game
stand up acting wise i study movies i
study performances so just this movie
and this podcast should let you know
that if you work hard
something will happen the universe will
[__] reward you and that's what
happens when your maturity and your
experience take over a situation i love
you [__] with all my heart
ice cream shop is stocked up with
laughing gas and it's better than
[__] ever
better than ever that new crop is
[__] killing [__] because
i've had like three or four of my
friends call me so they're back on you
go there today monday and copy your
[__] self
beside that it's a [__] beautiful
month to be alive the leaves are
changing my dick is bigger than ever and
we're all ready to [__] rock
uh i love you [__] thank you
for the support thank you for the
support on the many saints
and we're done with the many saints
we're on to the next [__] mind [__]
i'll see you for [__] wednesday
tip top magoo ready to rock and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack stay black
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for listening today
listen to many saints was great it's
over now i wanted to tell you a couple
funny stories so we can move the [__] on
but real quick the joint is brought to
you by blue chew why [__] around with
that half-loaded [__] it's the lord's
day [__] it's monday it's time for
you to go out there and sling dick with
two hands and blue chew is here to help
you blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost you don't have to go to [__]
mexico
and talk to mexican people you can take
it anytime day or night the process is
simple sign up at bluetooth.com
talk to their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved boom your
prescription is arise within days the
best part is it's all online no sitting
like an idiot in the doctor's office
no cute nurses giggling at you no
pharmacist they're giving you the
browbeat nother bluetooth tablets are
made in the u
s of a and prepare to ship directly it's
way cheaper in the pharmacy and nobody
knows what's in that package not even
the farm not even the mailman so there's
no one no embarrassment you know what
i'm saying it's a nice discreet package
you can benefit from extra confidence
correct when it's time to sling dick
with three hands and blue shoes gotcha
they got a special deal for you also try
blue chew
free joey it's monday don't [__] with my
emotions listen i'm gonna make your
weekend even [__] better with
bluetooth.com
use promo code joey and just pay the fin
for shipping five dollars for shipping
that's it that's bluechu.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month for free
f-r-e-e and as always i want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the joint
the joint is also brought to you by my
one of my favorites why because they're
the best draftkings listen they're the
official sports betting partner the nfl
and the ufc what the [__] are you
waiting on all these other sports
betting companies coming at you with
their special offers but nobody delivers
like draftkings they're reliable they're
safe and secure withdraw your money
whenever the [__] you want draftking
sportsbook app the official sports
betting partner of the nfl has a [__]
deal you should jump on for week five
this week new customers can bet one
dollar on any nfl game and win a yard
stick that's a hundred dollars in free
bets where you gonna get that action at
draftkings are you [__] kidding me or
what the last zero zero time the nfl was
that's older than [__] uncle joey
we're making you some money this week
we got the nfl we got college ball we
got the baseball playoffs the nf
nba is back next week or two october
18th
this is your chance to make some real
money this winter
and if your sports book isn't available
in your state yet draftkings won't leave
you empty-handed i know you guys love to
play fantasy and draftkings has huge
cash prizes and the best draftkings
daily fantasy out there but you got to
download the draftkings fantasy app
they're giving all new customers a free
shot at a million dollars
you like the [__] fantasy sign up use
promo code joey
with your first deposit download the
draftking sportsbook app download the
draftkings fantasy app use promo code
joey throw one dollar on any any nfl
game and we're gonna give you a hundred
dollars in free bets if either team
scores a point that's promo code joey
this week at draftkings sportsbook app
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl now here's the stuff the lawyer
makes me say you got to be 21 and older
go get the [__] skateboard you ain't
got time for this [__] over here new
jersey indiana pa only colorado new
customers only minimum final deposit and
a dollar wage is required
one per customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if we got a
gaming problem let's take care of it
that's called 1-800 gambler let's hit
some meetings you don't need this in
your life even though draftkings is the
safe has could come
you can't go over your head on
draftkings so do me a favor if you don't
have a problem and you're prepared
download the draftking sportsbook app
download the draftkings uh fantasy app
and let's win some [__] getus the
joint is also brought to you by
one of my favorites and proven
c b d lion wow unbelievable you
understand me they're the best [__]
cbd out there from the capsules to the
kinesiology tape to the vapor pens to
the back balls
i mean listen i've been with them for
two years and they are
just [__] fantastic
cbd line is as good as it [__] gets
in my world i've tried all the cbds
and they do not compare
i was down on cbd when cbd line came
into my life how's that for you put that
your pipe in smoking so do me a favor go
to cbdline.com read the third-party lab
results
see how cbd can benefit you the benefits
of cbn the benefits of cby and let's get
this [__] party started pushing
code joey and get 20 off delivered to
your house i want to thank cbd lion i
want to thank blue chew and i want to
thank draftkings but most importantly i
want to thank you [__] savages for
always having my back on a monday and
wednesday morning and for having my back
for the last 10 years thank you for
watching the many saints and laughing
gas is back in stock stay black
[__] uncle joey loves you i'll
see you wednesday tip top [__]
magoo
laid back
[Music]
so
you